Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
Show. My final day, sitting in for David while
he is away. I didn't mean for that to be Dr.
Seuss. It just sometimes it happens when you're
exhausted from trying to keep up the pace of
David Pac-man's work schedule, which, by the way,
off the charts. My hat is off. The have
I don't wear is off to to David for the
wild wild amount of work that he puts in
not just in video creation but also the
live streams that he it's just it is bananas.
So you should be very thankful for Mr. Pacman.
Listen, if it's not abundantly clear already
that Donald Trump is not interested in democracy,
in fact, he is a direct opponent of it, then
you haven't been paying enough attention.
Donald Trump is in it for himself, whether it be
to protect himself from legal liability in several
cases that have presented themselves
as a direct result of his criminality
or just wanting power and to be able to to glean
as much money out of the presidency as he can.
And even if it means by force, even
if it means inflaming the passions
of already violently ready
to go hordes of supporters.
I don't think I need to, but I'm going to
remind you of all or many, many, many of
the violent things that happened on the campaign
trail in 2016. His either condoning or calling
for violence directly. Remember these moments?
Speaker 2: I don't know if I'll do the fighting
myself or if other people will. Maybe he should
have been roughed up because it was absolutely
disgusting what he was doing. But if you see
somebody getting ready to throw a tomato,
knock the crap out of. But would you seriously
like to punch him in the face? I'll tell you.
Try not to hurt him. If you do, I'll defend you in
court. Don't worry about it. In the good old days,
this doesn't happen because they used to treat
them very, very rough. And when they protested
once, you know, they would not do it again so
easily. We become weak. We become weak. And you
know what? The audience swung back and I thought
it was very, very appropriate. The audience hit
back. And that's what we need a little bit more of
now. Part of the problem and part of the reason it
takes so long is nobody wants to hurt each other
anymore. Right. I don't know if I would have done
well, but I would have been out there fighting.
I don't know what I would have done well,
but I would have been blown bombo up.
Speaker 1: Beat that.
Do you plan on paying for the legal
fees of this older gentleman in
North Carolina who sucker punch the protester?
Speaker 2: From what I understand, he was sticking
a certain finger up in the air. And that is a
terrible thing to do in front of somebody that
frankly wants to see America made great again.
Speaker 1: It's possible you could help him
with legal fees of this man needs it.
Speaker 2: I've actually instructed
my people to look into it. Yes.
Speaker 1: And that is not even to
mention the violence that took place
on January six where Trump incited
whipped his followers, his fan base,
his his loyal adherents into a frenzy
to the point that they attacked the United States
Capitol, our temple of democracy, some call it.
People died. A deadly failed coup attempt at
the hands of Donald Trump. But by the way,
he's being sued for by Congress, members of
Congress right now and former and current police
officers for violating the Ku Klux Klan Act. We
witnessed him gassed peaceful protesters a block
away from the White House. Violence is order.
It's the order of the day for Donald Trump.
And I think he realizes and many Republicans
realize, that his only path to power, it's
certainly not through the popular vote. His only
path to power is through violence or the threat
of violence. And he wants to prepare his people
for that eventuality. He wants to get them ready,
primed for it. And he's notching up
he's he's taking it to the next level.
He recruits this re posted this particular message
all truth social to his millions of followers.
Then they will have to figure out how to
fight 80 million plus. It's not going to
happen again. People my age and old will
physically fight for him this time. What
We got to lose all donate the rest of my time
here on this planet to do it. And I know many,
many others who feel the same. They've
got my six and we are locked and loaded.
Donald Trump retweeted that. I mean, I say
retweeted because true social is just a carbon
copy rip off of Twitter. He retrieved
it. He reposted this to his millions.
This is a tacit endorsement of this idea. We
are locked and loaded. We have our firearms,
our weapons of war, locked and loaded,
ready to go. And we will physically fight
to ensure a second term for Donald Trump.
And nothing. It's crickets. Certainly
crickets from Republicans. But is this not?
Incitement to violence. Certain. Listen,
there is no absolute rights. People call
themselves free speech absolutists or dipshits.
Because even Scalia, when he was alive,
Antonin Scalia pushed back on absolutism
with rights. The Second Amendment, for instance,
you don't have an absolute right to any weapon
that you'd like. There are limitations.
There are limitations to free speech.
And this has to be one of them. Adam Kinzinger.
He tweeted this about it. He said, this is sick,
sick, sick. Is it even legal to invite this kind
of stuff? And I would ask the same question.
This is not cute. This is not Donald Trump
just trying to get clicks. This is real.
The same people who would oh, this is they
would dismiss this are the same people who
dismissed that there was a legitimate domestic
terrorist threat surrounding the insurrection
surrounding January 6th. And look what
happened. We can no longer afford to ignore
this. Government, federal officials, the
Department of Justice, the FBI, whomever,
Please get off of your hands and do
something. The fact that he is the
president of the United States makes it even
more of an obligation on your part. Please.